the second last episode of lovecraft
country is here and i may just have to
go back in time to watch them all over
again
you've got to come back with me back to
the future and also to beat the crap out
of some races
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into episode 9 breaking down a
journey through
time and what it could mean for the
season finale so get in your deloreans
or multiverse time machines and make
sure to like and subscribe
a quick disclaimer before we begin one i
haven't read the book so you won't get
any spoilers here for that
and two the show depicts instances of
racial injustice and discrimination
something i'm continually educating
myself on
so if i've gotten something wrong or
missed something please send me a dm or
comment below
well diana doesn't seem to be doing well
after being cursed
by captain lancaster her arm has decayed
and she's turned into some coma-like
topsy and bopsy characters from the book
uncle tom's cabin who have taken on a
demonic
form everyone's pointing fingers at how
this could have happened but the truth
is
no one was there for her including her
mother hippolyta who hasn't been seen
since the end of episode 7. atticus and
letty are also here after their
encounter with a rogue shoghoth last
episode
it seems to have vanished and they'll
later tell christina that the
accident outside was the result of a gas
explosion
christina doesn't seem to know what
happened one of the theories i had last
episode was that she controlled the
shogus we've seen her do this before
she even aided in the birth of one but
it looks like this shogoth was acting on
its own
christina is brought in to help dee at
ruby's request
atticus initially was going to ask her
to help dee in exchange for titus's
pages
not knowing that letty already gave them
to her in exchange for her protection
spell
one that will come in extremely handy in
this episode
this decision however isn't without its
consequences as montrose says he'll
never forgive her for doing something
that may kill his son
but you handing over those pages you
might have a hand in the death of my son
christina goes over dee's drawings dee
drew a picture of the demon last episode
and it looks as though she's left
several of them recounting the events of
what happened to her since
nobody was around these allow christina
to deduce that she was cursed by captain
lancaster
and the only thing that can save her is
either lancaster himself
or the book of names and the book of
names was burned in the tulsa massacre
way back in 1921.
as we saw at the end of last episode
lancaster was severely wounded by the
shogoth we see he's still alive and two
of his men attempt
putting him back together using a spell
and the body parts of a black man
but it doesn't seem to work that's
because christina had ruby put a
special rune in his office preventing
lancaster's regeneration
it's extra fitting that she shows up as
william to watch him die
as it was lancaster was responsible for
william's death
the only question i'm wondering here is
did christina know this was going to
happen
hence her putting the rune there far in
advance or if it was just
forward thinking christina tells the
group that she can cast a restorative
spell on d
but all it will do is reset the cycle
it's pretty much a band-aid fix that
will buy them some time and she agrees
to do it in exchange for atticus coming
with her to artem on the night of the
autumnal equinox the night where it's
believed she'll kill atticus to obtain
immortality in order to make this spell
for d work they'll need the blood of the
closest relative
and since her mother hippolyta is gone
that leaves montrose but
montrose may not be the father that's
why he tells atticus that
george might be his dad some really bad
timing since hippolyta returns moments
later after spending 200 years on earth
504
she went through the multiverse machine
to a different earth and has returned
part cyborg and with
tech that can be used to fix the machine
with their help they can go back in time
retrieve the book of names from 1921 and
save d
meanwhile ruby confronts christina about
her plan to kill
atticus and to be honest i was a bit
taken aback about how
okay ruby was with christina's plan she
basically just says make sure not to
hurt letty
we get this text message showing the
observatory is in kentucky but a few
episodes ago it said it was in mayfield
kansas along with hippolyta's map that
said kansas as well
you may have thought what's going on
here but it's simply a production error
as showrunner misha green tweeted out
that the observatory is in fact in
mayfield kentucky
montrose isn't doing well drinking
moonshine haunted by the voice of his
father who beat him for putting a flower
in his hair one of the big aspects of
this episode is the effect of
intergenerational trauma how montrose
was beaten by his father
and did the same exact thing to atticus
he'll end up telling letty that atticus
knows about her baby
because he saw it in the future a future
where he finds out he dies to
christina's spell
hippolyta says all she needs is a
motherboard for the machine to work so
she connects herself a mother to it
using the cybernetic risk she acquired
in episode 7. the plan is to retrieve
the book of names from atticus's
mother's house and come straight back
trying not to alter time and
simultaneously avoiding one of the most
violent
racist attacks ever committed on
american soil the tulsa massacre
an event which lasted two days and a
2001 oklahoma state commission
estimated anywhere from 75 to 300 dead
6 000 injured and 10 000 homeless
tulsa at the time was known as black
wall street and had the wealthiest black
community in the united states
it was completely wiped out in two days
the event largely omitted from
local state and national history books
atticus letty and montrose take the
portal to 1921 where they dress in
period clothing to fit in you may recall
two girls in the hallway talking about
the dance being cancelled because some
white folks were
koo clucking at the courthouse this is a
reference to the catalyst which started
the massacre a young black man named
dick roland was being held at the
courthouse
for an alleged assault on a white woman
an assault which never happened the
woman in question never even pressed
charges but sensational headlines like
this one from the tulsa tribune
added fuel to the fire as mobs of armed
white men descended on the courthouse
looking to lynch this resulted in a
group of armed black men to come to
roland's defense
offering their help to the sheriff to
defend roland the moment that triggered
all hell breaking loose is said to have
happened when a white man demanded one
of the black defenders hand over his
pistol
after he refused a shot was fired and a
firefight ensued
starting what would be known as the
tulsa massacre we get to see
downtown tulsa and the beautiful
dreamland theater which featured
prominently in the watchmen series
which was probably my favorite show of
last year if you like lovecraft you'll
love
watchmen plus i have a ton of videos on
it the hotel they teleport into is the
stratford hotel
one of the most luxurious hotels in the
state and was owned by
john b stratford the richest black man
in tulsa montrose literally relives a
scene where his father tells him to pick
a switch a term for pick a sticker rod
to be beaten with we'll see him get
beaten by a branch for putting a flower
in his hair
and maybe this will give some context to
atticus why his dad turned out the way
he did
young george watches and does nothing
something young dora chastises him for
you might recall in episode 1 that
atticus gets upset at george for
never doing anything when montrose beat
him so this is in line with his
character
atticus and letty lose track of montrose
and decide to split up
lety will get the book while atticus
goes after his father but not before
letty acknowledges
atticus knows about the baby saying they
should name him george which they
do as we see in atticus's book he
obtained from the future
written by his son george freeman letty
takes refuge in the freeman home as mobs
of angry white men
burn the city down it's here she'll meet
hattie atticus's great grandmother and
convince her to hand over the book of
names
something she's able to do in large part
to knowing about the family birthmark
there's a great shot of letty holding a
gun as she watches the insanity outside
reminding me of the malcolm x photo
titled by any means
necessary hattie will give letty the
book of names but it's too late for her
the fire in the home will consume her
but not letty she is the invulnerability
spell allowing her to survive
something we'll see on full display as
she walks through the war-torn
streets of downtown tulsa book of names
in hand
meanwhile atticus catches up with
montrose to find him watching his
younger self and a boy named thomas a
boy he couldn't be with
because he was gay montrose tells
atticus that he cut out all the soft
parts of himself to be a man
this is how he had to survive being a
gay black man
even though atticus may not be his son
montro says
i did it all and i would do it again
because the only thing i ever wanted to
be was your father
george and dora come to save montrose
but are accosted by a group of white
thugs
atticus coming to the rescue with a
baseball bat to fight them off
hearkening back to the jackie robinson
imagery from his dream in
episode 1. montrose had previously told
atticus about a mysterious stranger with
a baseball bat that saved them that
night
little did he know it would be atticus
confirming that we
are in a time loop what happens now has
happened before
and will happen again sonia sanchez's
poem catch the fire is played as letty
praised with hattie surrounded by
actual fire sanchez was one of the major
voices in the civil rights women's lib
and black arts movement her poem
encourages people to be aware of
injustice
i say where is your fire can't you smell
it coming out of our past
letty makes her way through the street
says an operatic requiem place requiems
are musical pieces sung for the souls of
the dead this particular piece was sung
by renowned african american soprano
janae brugger
who had to record this in a makeshift
studio made of blankets in her home due
to the pandemic
as montrose waits for letty he recounts
stories of those who died
their voices silenced by history like dr
jackson the most renowned black surgeon
in
america who was killed that night
montrose leddy and atticus make it back
to present day but not without hippolyta
levitating and morphing into arithia
blue to keep the portal stable
she spits out white liquid reminiscent
of androids in the alien universe and
her eyes gloss over white as well
this hippolyta ain't the same hippolyta
and that's where the episode leaves us
the group having successfully acquired
the book of names but attic is still
owing his presence to christina at
artem now we're not sure how atticus
will get out of this situation but i
think the key lies in gia
as misha green tweeted she'll be back
and knowing her powers who knows what an
effect it will have on the spell
and christina's plan with only one more
episode left i hope you'll join me next
week for the final lovecraft country
breakdown
thanks for watching make sure to like
subscribe and share and for more bad
takes follow me on instagram and twitter
at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much